sap sollte mal was raussuchen ja bitte
was würdest du jetzt gerade machen wenn
du nicht youtube gemacht der epischen
legende mit einer altbewährten
konstellation mit contra von jon bon
giorno meine lieben baguette und
magazinen hallo erstmal heil und schon
ist doch gar nicht französisch nee das
ist mir auch aufgefallen die ist man
auch italien mein lieber freund pakets
ist man auch in italien einen guten
morgen meine liebe pizza und spaghetti
nie egal wir wieder ein twitter hashtag
gemacht und ich bin schon in der stadt
kef menschen also ich habe bei mir der
letzten folge sagt der chef der hubi zur
innenstadt der song super plan und alles
aber ich bin schon wieder hier weil ich
einfach ein portal benutzt habe was ich
gemacht habe den letzten folgen was ein
sehr großes problem ist und zwar ich bin
auf der suche nach zwei fouls ich habe
glaube ich könnte welche geben wieso
wofür brauchst wären es gibt diese
normalen slime gold von den grünen
schleimen und ich habe nachgeschaut und
wie die spawnen und ob die spawnen aber
es braucht einfach ein scheiß nirgends
du hast gar keine slums quasi es gebe
schon ist leims aber das sind dann so
blaue slams und die drop eine andere art
von slime ball so ein englisches ist ein
ball oder so heißt er und den kann man
für manche rezepte nicht verwenden
und das ist kacke weil ich will mir ich
will mir so eine pistole machen ich habe
auch schon alle teile lassen alle teil
ist glaub ich rad drops oder so dann
habe ich alle zusammen und ich will doch
nur noch dienst leihen wollen was fertig
zu machen weil ich habe das jetzt
natürlich wissen gespoilert was ich denn
machen werde
dann machst du dir nämlich auch hab das
nicht mal hässlich niveau das von den
leuten vorgeschlagen es
nehme dieses keystone oder wie auch
immer mit munition
man kann sich so dass ende aber machen
und das ist so sobald ich auch nur in
deine richtung schieße ohne dich zu
treffen
trifft ich diese ändern munition
hundertprozentiger sie direkt zu dir
teleportiert und die matte relativ gut
schaden
das heißt wenn ich einfach so ein ganzes
magazin das kann ich im realfall wie die
weg feiern dann ist eigentlich so gut
wie jeder gegner eigentlich immer tot
weil selbst wenn er weg fliegen sollte
den knall ich halt so weg das ist auf
jeden fall ein guter plan was ich habe
gerade noch mal geguckt für dich und
zwar ich habe gar keine slums ich gar
nicht gedacht habe auch nur diese
delicious teile ja aber ich hatte aber
nicht gedacht
ich dachte ich hätte welche ich habe
immer gesucht habe gestern könnte ich
dir anbieten dass auch diese anderen das
ist draußen ganz normal grünen slime
ball
wenn ich jetzt mal rat überlege ich habe
auch noch wenig bis gar keine grünen
slums gesehen nur diese blauen halten ja
genau und das ding ist dann wurde mir
ich habe den leuten also jetzt die
gestrige folge waren nur zwei besucher
das heißt nichts gefallen da gar nichts
gefunden und dass die leute sollten wir
beantworten wo ich vielleicht kleins
finde und da kommt natürlich die
diversen spekulationen warum denn es
gibt ja so nach zwei insel island das
ist dann in der luft so eine kleine
slime island und genauso luft insel java
wie geil
also in der wikio nachgeschaut das gibt
es tatsächlich aber ich war er steht
nicht in welcher version manche sagen
wir fühlen sich in dieser version die
wir spielen in der nächsten wir denken
ja bald sogar ab den server glaube ich
würden uns mit der in natürlich du
bezüglich willst du mit mir ausgehen
aber nur wenn wir uns im rotlichtmilieu
treffen wenn
in seiner bude genau die atmosphäre
nämlich stimmig wenn du mal mitfahren
will kann ich dir mein hammer geben wir
normal mit vorkommen hast dann fünfter
mit 9 x auf einmal die frage ist ja
widerlich flieger in die stadt ich bin
ja glaube ich durch die halbe welt
geflogen damit ich neue sumpf biome
finde weil ich habe in erinnerung es war
noch ganz damals so dass die nur auf
super flat map spawnen oder nicht ich
kann mich nun zum verändern
aufseher für die das war noch ganz davor
dass die unter der höhe von 15 sein
mussten in einem spezifischen islam bio
das war ganz am anfang
danach haben die das weg gemacht und
gesagt slime spawnen nur noch morgens
und abends im sumpf und jetzt wenn man
mal gar nichts das ist richtig mysteriös
also ich bin durch will jetzt mal in der
stadt gleich protection the way kann ich
das machen was ich am besten kann
während der aufnahme im internet surfen
war ich so häufig in letzter zeit ich
weiß nicht wieso aber wieder drauf was
andere leute im portal geschrieben es
gibt in eurer version leider keine slime
islands dann schon mal richtig geld
richtig motivieren wenn ich sowas leben
selbst keinen durch slams können wie du
gesagt hast mit dem mond sporne es gibt
auch slime tanks unter der erde
okay das heißt könnte sein dass die
nicht raus genommen wurden aber naja
bietet diese mini map slime tanks an
glanz es gibt noch minimap sind uns
umstellen kann zeigen sich dann was
chance man hat's ob man das im bio und
weiß was meine ja ich weiß was du meinst
eigentlich müsste das geht also bei der
flak minimap ging das immer
dass man das halt so umstellen konnte ja
ich schau mal kurz ob in web gui ist auf
ambac da ich heute sam sei nirgendwo
entwickelt hat da haben wir noch
irgendwann alle wixforth du in deiner
falle slappnig smart teleport was
verdiene ich gucke schon selbst eben da
am bass oder das zeigt mir gar nicht
freuen wenn ich einfach mal auf ein
thema eingehen
von den zuschauern die uns wieder
reichlich etwas in die in die twitter
timeline geschrieben haben sollte man
was raussuchen
ja bitte was würdest du jetzt gerade
machen wenn du nicht youtube gemacht hat
ist die frage ist ein bisschen
kompliziert aber wenn man jetzt nicht
mit youtube angefangen hätte was wird
man in dieser zeit machen die man jetzt
ein youtube investiert hatte also das
ding ist ich hab ja sowieso angefangen
zu studieren
dollar ich habe sowieso angefangen zu
studieren und dann habe ich parallel mit
youtube angefangen das heißt bei mir
stellt sich die frage nicht insofern
weil ich studiere ja immer noch das
heißt ich würde einfach weiter schwierig
noch nicht durch bin
ach so ja das klingt logisch aber mir
wäre es auch so ich bin die ganze zeit
noch magath mein abi und ich denke ich
wird einfach viel mehr für die schule
tun und gar nicht die ganzen stadt hier
werden party und saufen
ja das ist nämlich auch so die sache und
zwar wenn ich zum beispiel warte warte
ich habe den hammer hingeworfen aber
irgendwie bitte an die frage sagt muss
man hasst hinbekommen ich wirklich auch
hier war boden geworfen würde diese
reckels also die schenken aber den nicht
ganz immerhin zurückgeben irgendwann du
hast doch ich habe zum abbau na ja genau
ok danke ja bei mir ist es nämlich zum
beispiel ich glaube jetzt am wochenende
genau gleich und zwar dann ist man am
wochenende mal los feiern
und denkt dann aber immer schon so nein
ich brauche mal nach dem video also im
moment des fans denkt man nicht so dran
aber wenn man dann am morgen aufwacht
und dann so um zwei us aufwacht oder so
denke ich mir dann immer so scheiße du
brauchst noch ein video schnell
aufstehen duschen alles mögliche und das
denke ich mir so immer dabei das ist
dann da hat man so ein bisschen mehr
ruhe sage ich mal weil es ist halt
mittlerweile man muss es wirklich sagen
es ist eigentlich wie ein beruf das muss
man sagen natürlich also youtube ist ja
auch das ist ja wie viele denken sich
nur 15 minuten folgejahr des chili milli
des tages es ist ja vorbereitung
nachbereitung und muss ja konzepte
überlegen dann wie seit sauberhalten
spam weg machen mit den anderen in
kontakt treten auch wenn auch diverse
andere gespräche die man für muss damit
es auch weiter laut weitere
kooperationsverträge besprechen pipapo
also eigentlich schon richtig viel also
vor allem dieses dass man sich mit dem
material beschäftigt weil wenn man sich
damit nicht beschäftigt dann bringt zeit
nix weil man muss sich damit weniger
beschäftigen lesen der funktionieren
soll
und die frage ist gibt es eine
möglichkeit dass man irgendwie zurück
kräfte
ach da ist gar kein zelt auf dem hammer
drauf der nähe so logisch
man kann man nicht in diese straftat
nähe weil den kann man gar nicht
verzogen den hammer alles blöd ist das
ein kaka für dich ja egal am park ist
halt den ofen sollte jetzt nicht weiter
schlimm sein aber trotzdem killer ist es
dinge die ich krass ab man denke an sich
ist relativ langsam als mord immer neuen
blöcke ab also das glaube ich halb so
schnell wie die größte effizienz die man
haben kann aber dafür bezahlt 9 ab das
halt das was geiles ich habe jetzt
gehört oder gelesen
mach dir aus diesen komischen größeres
slime 1 die pisten und den kann man dann
irgendwie wieder zurück greifen
aber wie kann man zurückgreifen
aber kämpfen wollen wir erstmal hier ne
also die frage war es auf jeden fall war
ganz interessant sondern frage hab jetzt
auch noch nicht gelesen eigentlich so
was würdet ihr machen denn jetzt nicht
youtuber seiten um jetzt nur weil sie
nicht also halt einfach mehr zeit mit
dingen verbringen die eigentlich dann
wichtig in unserem leben wäre ja ich
habe glaube ich ich habe es glaube ich
war ja wirklich auf schlag ich habe mir
nämlich irgendwann mal als ich mit dem
hammer experimentiert habe habe ich so
eine fehlkonstruktion gemacht dass ich
so und du bist das ihre konstruktionen
hammer gebaut habe aber nichts bringt
dachte ich zumindest mit dem gleichen
finde ich jetzt nicht wieder oder was
komm schon bitte wenn minecraft gott
wenn du oben bist ja bestimmt schon mit
stunde lang die pisten es gibt ja meine
lieben freunde freut sich auch über die
kleinen dinge im leben alter dem
epischen ende stand jedoch gut für
unsere stadt
danke leute ich muss ich bedanke mich
auch direkt bei der person wie wir das
rein geschrieben hat oki hat alles in
camps geschrieben egal
der kino 66 666 65 danke also ja es caps
geschrieben hab mich parallel bei der
jüngsten wahlerfolge geguckt und heißt
wirkt alles gewesene wie geil hammer ok
krass ich werde jetzt immer noch so ein
bisschen ich baue er immer noch so eine
stadtweite die essensausgabe ich habe
ich auch wieder aufgefüllt du
menschenskinder läuft auf einmal hier
war zeigen was von egal pistole ich habe
nein nicht sterben doch ich zeig ich
habe noch keine munition mit kräften sie
cool die pistole war schon mal sehr geil
aber dass ohne eine magnum ist aber die
idee nicht nur gut aus sondern ist die
auch cool ich bin wo bin ich statt blau
doch ach komm mir zu meinem alten haus
davor stehst musst du zurückgehen
ich sehe dich wenn ihr gerne
gemeinschaftlich an arbeiten hier kommt
dir das mal an
das ist ein geiles teil alter egal
diesem magnum aussieht ich hab ne waffe
ich hab da war völlig im sommer hatte
hier will sie die vom aussehen her die
es gerne gemacht aber so ohne die macht
so keinen schaden macht es nicht anders
das geht sich jetzt habt ihr jetzt schon
von diesem habkern ist richtig gut
gesehen dass banken wächst braucht noch
irgendwelche ressourcen dazu oder das
einzige was sie bräuchten würde braucht
brauchen würde tun sein wer miniatur
herzen dafür muss ich halt man dungeons
gehen aber zurzeit nicht mehr so an die
pflanzen auf meiner farm team herrlich
will ich hab' ich habe hätte was gesagt
ich hab davon glauben zu 20 stück
verschenkt an andere städte hkm einer
kiste gepackt
ja ich kenne an und die sind halt so ich
geh hus ohne eine bild wird jetzt mit
über all diese bode beobachtet alles
hashtag stadt pink schilder das ist so
nervig des budo motto ist das was
hässlich ist do
die haben
ich habe meine stadt finke packen das
wirklich bibel auf den tisch ging was
die da kommunizieren dann hat er mir
erzählt dass bono wem herrscher ist und
eigentlich finde ich das konzept weil
das ist eigentlich ganz witzig wenn ihr
dann überlege damals vw-stadt pink den
wurde verboten dass die aggressiv sind
und so die mama dann dass sie aggressiv
sind ja dass die andere haben mich
getötet
genau die dürfen nicht angreifen ist ein
du bleibst an aber die anhören sich auf
ihre eigenen regeln und deswegen ist das
irgendwo die habe ich auch übrigens in
meinem haus getötet
nur du musst ja zu bauen dürfen sich
halt nicht rein portman haus was meinst
du deswegen ich meine türen so
verbarrikadiert habe ja gut bei mir ich
hatte eh alles verzaubert und ich hab
ich nichts verloren von daher war das
relativ egal wie ich einmal wieder
gestoppt
das ist gut so in letzter zeit sterbe
ich nie ich habe auch da spielt auch
altgold minecraft expertin daher als
übelster pvp pro gilt wer sagt anja fait
machen ich sag dann sogar gleich musst
du bist meine sachen reparieren weil ich
habe meinen job verlor ist gestorben ist
funkel ist einfach mal und dann habe ich
mich fertig gemacht und er auch dann
haben gesagt okay ohne flug starb
einfach einer kompletten stadt blaue
laufbahn um und ich hätte ihnen klatsch
geklatscht sein schwert war einfach weg
wirklich einfach weg wie wir beide
denken es war weg das schwert erschwert
es weg ist einfach weg war ja keine
ahnung
ja bei mir war das halt bei der schmiede
ach so das ist das loch in der rein
gehst 1 person eine kleine konstruktion
grund erfolgte das ja so machen das
hatten wir ja weil bei dir hat man
gesehen
du hast alles reingepackt es hat sich
aber nicht geschmolzen und das hängt
damit zusammen dass wenn der server neu
gestartet hängt sich das auf und genau
deswegen will ich da so eine letzte und
konstruktion machen damit es nicht
durchgängig läuft sondern wie man den
schalter umlegt dann kriegt er einfach
los so zu sagen okay das habe ich
angefangen aber im juni zu ende gedacht
auch gut dass mich anders weil du hast
immer aluminium nee ich glaube nicht
irgendwas ist da ist es nicht mal 1
gewesen
dann hat das eine rausgenommen also in
der letzten folge von mir die ich jetzt
heute auch schon halt aufgenommen hat
verwirrend
die halle ist heute noch kommt peter
kinold aluminium hier ist ja wie kriegt
das jetzt daraus das ist meins er wird
deswegen deswegen habe ich ja den timer
jede ware haben wir jetzt an den timer
ok cool so war es das wirklich mal
zeigen ist das meist seien vermutlich
schon mainz ist es nicht mal dass mich
jemand direkt raus und sonst könnte es
eigentlich nur kilos nächster zeit nicht
aufhöre hast du daten stick oder wie
sich nicht auf natürlich demnach
allerdings nach der aufnahme
wieso hast du ein stick zufällig war
zwei holz doch tochter oder irgend weil
ich das ding irgendetwas mit dem
einstieg machen kann
ich will nicht alter ich muss gerade
alle sachen sollte mich auch
funktionieren ja ich muss alle sachen
von mir jetzt in andere kisten packen
ich muss die ganze kisten umlegen er
jetzt vor kein platz war wie es zu
diesen kisten wildhaber der funktioniert
ich bei den diamanten kisten ja wieso
optimum diamant kisten ist doch nicht
klar in nicht klug weil die größer sind
wir streben bei der wahl der läuft beste
lebe besser leben echte leben angelo
concorso warte hier die feile müsse ich
da reinpacken
also ich mache mir jetzt übels viele
magazin ich will einfach wenn ich das
dann habe will ich nur wenig wert
genannt ich bin der schnellste gold in
mexiko alter wirklich schlecht was ich
schnitze colt colt okay ja bitte
wo dein hama wo soll ich denn schmerzen
dürfte mir auch friedrich kommen gleich
okay kann sich an bord in eine kiste tun
aber
ich weiß einfach daten einen unfall hin
wien ein
im falle des ponys übertrieben schnell
alles loswerden
jetzt habe ich über einen stack magazine
das ist gut ist euch richtig viele inder
schutz
er liegt vor der natur auferlegt vor
deiner tür jedoch nicht fakt kann ich
dann ist leibolz haben bitte ich habe
keine hast du diese klischees die wenn
du sie findest kannst du sie haben ich
finde ja selber gerade nicht mehr leute
wieder eingesammelt ja geil weil das
ding ist ich habe jetzt die möglichkeit
wie ich die umwandeln kann also einen
davon in ein normales langweilig wurde
es hier ist einer hinter dir hier ist
nicht drin
nichts wie ab hast du dein hammer
eingesammelt okay gut so und ich weiß
mittenwald stehen überall deswegen ich
muss ja gerade mal sortieren so eine
sortier arbeit ich habe auch wenn ich
meine dass in der folge habe da wirklich
zwei stunden im livestream sortiert nur
zwei stunden war ich fertig und egal ich
muss erstmal die ganzen kiste neben
hinaus reinpacken
am liebsten hätte ich ich glaube ich
mache jetzt einen großen rucksack wo ich
ganz viel unnötige sache rein packe also
irgendwie hast du gar kein holz mehr
hast du noch mehr kisten an die darin
mischen ja auch welche wirklich überall
ein bisschen was ist ein tablett
ach so also leder und string also ich
glaub du hast ja ich weiß es nicht muss
halt nein das ist ja kacke weil das ding
ist wenn ich diese ender shots vier
schüsse brauchen ein slime wolf von
diesem ex diesen sehr sehr aufwendig zu
kräften und das ding ist einfach also in
slough ist das wieder das ist eigentlich
mist ganz toller und gold nugget aber
ich weiß nicht was daraus passiert
klicke ich die hülsen wieder oder wie es
dass das egal wenn ich dieses siegs
shots wieder kriegen würde das inventar
das weiß ich halt nicht aber wir sind
wieder bei 20 minuten mit ich würde ja
was sagen in der nächsten folge machen
com crafter und ich wieder weitere
fragen von euch bei twitter rhinow
deswegen passt das ganz gut
und ansonsten würde ich einfach sagen
schaut auch bei mir als anderen vorbei
bleibt bloß macht gut bis dann